[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's ein basic rezept ich zeige
euch wie man hefe trägt zubereitet auch
ohne küchenmaschine und daraus werde ich
gleich einen monkey brett zu bereiten
und zwar ist es so eine art zubrot aber
erst kuchen denn ich mache jetzt ganz
süß und in süßer variante das ist dann
ein gebäck was man schön abzupfen kann
jetzt stelle ich mir im kopf die frage
warum heißt es überhaupt monkey brad
pitt weil die verbraucher das brot
abzupfen wie ein affe ja ich habe schon
viele affen im dschungel gesehen die
jemand geht brett mit den händen
abzufangen nicht okay
die menschen finden halt immer eine
geschichte drum egal wir stellen jetzt
erst mal ein hefeteig her
es zeigt euch mal kurz die zutaten für
den hefeteig nehme ich einen würfel hefe
20 gramm warmes wasser 50 gramm zucker
etwas vanille extrakt 500 gramm mehl
einen teelöffel salz 230 gramm mehl 2
eigelbe und 80 gramm weiche butter ja
also normalerweise würde ich den jetzt
einfach mit der küchenmaschine verkneten
vorher kurz die hefe mit dem wasser und
zucker verrühren
bei der küchenmaschine habt ihr einfach
den vorteil dass ihr die beiden hände
frei habt das heißt ihr könnt ihn
derzeit etwas anderes vorbereiten
ihr könnt aber auch ein handrührgerät
nehmen mit den knethaken vorne und da
aber wirklich nur am anfang den teig
kneten und je fester der teig wird umso
schwieriger wird es bis handrührgerät
also dann einfach am besten die hände
danach nehmen aber ich will euch jetzt
zeigen dass jeder hilfe direkt zu
bereiten also nehme ich jetzt einfach
die hände der hefe zucker und wasser
verrühren und ich nehme auch am liebsten
frische hefe das macht auch wirklichen
unterschied markant war es sagt doch die
industrie immer trockenhefe nehmen zwei
päckchen entsprechen einem frischen hefe
wirken aber ich finde frische hefe das
sind halt die hefe kulturen auch aktiv
und ich finde das funktioniert besser
und es schmeckt mir persönlich
besser mit frischhefe und ihr könnt ihr
auch gerne auf vorrat einfrieren also
ich habe eigentlich immer hilfe im
haushalt und dann immer gleich so einen
ganzen block im supermarkt also so ein
karton und kann es dann einfrieren und
dann bei bedarf einfach auftauen der
zucker und wasser sind verrührt bis hin
zu gar nicht und jetzt braucht ihr auch
keine schüssel ihr nehmt einfach eure
arbeitsfläche die saubere arbeit
da kommt es jetzt darauf in der mitte
eine mulde das salz kommt jetzt hier an
den rand nämlich immer besser wenn
zuerst die hefe mit dem zucker verrührt
wird und jetzt treten wir den teig so
die milch die erwärmung grad noch und
jetzt kommt die hefe mir schon in die
mitte und schütte sie auch gerne mal
daneben dann der restliche zucker jetzt
spüre ich immer erst mal in der gabel
ist auch gut gesagt ich mache den meist
wie gesagt mit der küchenmaschine aber
ihr könnt den teig schön auf der hand
verkneten
und jetzt einfach rühren nach und nach
auch die milch dazugeben
so erspart ihr euch erstmal eine große
sauerei mit den händen und ich nehme
hier mit der gabel jetzt immer mehr mail
vom rand dazu
und wenn ihr nicht so ein robuster
arbeitsplatte habt dann nimmt am besten
eine silikon löffel bevor ihr euch die
arbeitsplatte zerkratzt so und jetzt ist
die gabel am ende
ich nehme jetzt gleich die hände ich
kann mir das bitte sorgt genau im blog
schreiben jetzt ist die tafel am ende
ich nehme die hände
ok und jetzt kommen einfach alle
restlichen zutaten dazu also die eigelbe
immer schön alles auskratzen etwas
vanille extrakt
bei der butter macht das jetzt am besten
so nehmt einfach die butter mit der hand
raus und habt euch schonmal fertige
hände und jetzt einfach den teig
zusammen und jetzt wirklich so lange
kneten bisschen schöner geschmeidiger
teig entstanden ist und da ist auch
immer ganz gut dass die milch ein
bisschen warm ist und ihr merkt jetzt
auch wie sich die konsistenz des tages
ändert das heißt eigentlich habt echt
mit hand kneten den vorteil dass ihr
wisst wann die menge genug ist denn je
nach milchsorte verändert sich auch der
menge ich habe es hier ein dinkelmehl
und wenn ihr ein weiterleben kann sein
dass er einfach 20 gramm weniger braucht
arbeitsplatte sauber mit dem teig und
die märkte derzeit etwa zwei minuten
später aber ihr seht der teig der clip
dann immer weniger an den händen als
jetzt wirklich noch schön weiter kneten
bis er nicht mehr klebt und einen großen
tipp gibt noch beim kneten und zwar
sollt ihr nicht mit den fingern hier
vorne kneten also nicht so das bringt
dem teig relativ wenig und ihr seht dann
auch dann wird einfach nicht schön
geschmeidig sondern er hier mit dem
handballen okay also ich mache das immer
so und drückt den teig sozusagen mit dem
handballen ein und dadurch wieder eben
schön geknetet und ich würde sagen er
ist jetzt schon perfekt schön weich aber
nicht klebrig jetzt freu' mich eine
schöne kugel und ihr seht dann nämlich
einfach den teig von außen nach innen in
die mitte drehen dann oben da hab ich
eine schöne oberfläche
es geht nämlich besonders hübsch aus
jetzt kommt doch einfach in der schale
ich werde dir gerne mit back trance
break ihr könnt auch mehr nehmen damit
später einfach schön rauskommt und back
transporter auf die oberfläche oder
etwas öl
damit der teig nicht austrocknet und
jetzt abdecken und dann etwa eine halbe
stunde bis stunde aufgehen lassen bis er
sich verdoppelt hat einen dampf backofen
hat kann natürlich auch die gerbstoffe
benutzen da geht es ein bisschen
schneller da verkürzt man sozusagen die
aufgezeigt und dann geht es gleich
weiter
jetzt der teig schön aufgegangen und ich
nehme jetzt heraus gefüllt die teilchen
jetzt und zwar mit nougat ihr könnt auch
gerne macht übernehmen oder ein stück
schokolade haben hast echt gut und vor
allem habe ich jetzt hier ein
klassisches nougat nougat royal ein
bisschen heller und ein dunkles lukas
ein dunkles und einen dunklen lukas der
oder das geht beides hat es noch immer
ein bisschen komisch
na ja und ich sage ich auch ganz
praktisch denn ich kann dir gleich
einfach zu schneiden
die new kids stangen die habe ich jetzt
kurz eingefroren damit sei einfach schön
fest sind jetzt portioniert hier den
teig einfach viele kleine portionen
das habe ich jetzt die portionen den
nougat dann habe ich hier noch etwas
butter und zucker
die mutter habe ich jetzt einfach
geschmolzen den zucker gebe ich so noch
mit dazu
und jetzt nehme ich ein kügelchen öffne
es liegt ein stück nugg.ad rein und
verschließe es und dann leg ich kurz ab
sie werden gleich in der butter dann
gewälzt und dadurch entsteht eben auch
der effekt dieses manko brett das man es
später nach dem backen schön voneinander
zupfen kann weil die butter eben die
eigene die einzelnen kugeln schon
auseinander hält
jetzt sind alle gift hüllt und ich nehme
jetzt hier ein blech das fertig jetzt
kurz und ich habe jetzt hier auch eine
im ein schale die fertig auch denn die
wird mit gebacken
ich fühle jetzt sogar noch wasser rein
dann überhitzt zum einen die form nicht
und zum anderen habe ich so ein
wasserdampf perfekt im backofen perfekt
denn ich möchte dass die mitte frei
bleibt damit ich hier gleich da eine
soße rhein geben kann
ok und jetzt nehmt ihr die bällchen
legte ich hier in die butter zucker
mischung
ich glaube ich mache das jetzt einfach
so und dann lege ich dir hier einfach
ringsrum rennen
vor den rest die sich jedoch vorüber und
jetzt kommt das blech in den kalten
backofen dann schalte ich den backofen
an und mit der aufwärmzeit des backofens
gehen auch die bällchen noch mal schön
auf werden schön gebacken und in der
zwischenzeit bereit ich schon mal eine
vanillesoße zu ihr könnt sie selber
machen oder auch einfach eine fertige
soße nehmen aber selber machen geht auch
ganz schnell die vanillesoße geht auch
super einfach ihr braucht dafür nur 200
gramm sahne 200 gramm milch etwas
vanille extrakt zehn gramm stärke 40
gramm zucker eine prise salz und 2
eigelbe ich nehme es ihr dass vanille
extrakt und ihr seht es ist schon fast
leer aber so ein teelöffel bekomme ich
noch raus und da mache ich dann einfach
immer so ich spüre es aus mit der milch
dem dann könnt ihr wirklich das
komplette extrakt aufbrauchen und die
ganzen rest komme gut raus ich kann
jetzt hier schon mal alle zutaten im
topf war will
und jetzt einfach bei mittlerer hitze
eindecken lassen kurz aufkochen lassen
und währenddessen wirklich immer schön
rühren
jetzt ist alles fertig gebacken und ich
habe es auch ein bisschen abkühlen
lassen
die schale ob perfekte löst sich super
jetzt für dich das wasser aus dann kam
die schale wieder rein und die vanille
sauce die hatte ich jetzt noch abgedeckt
mit folie damit sich keine haut bildet
und wenn ihr die soße jetzt ganz kalt
verwenden wollt dann solltet ihr
vielleicht noch ein bisschen milch
zufügen
bei mir ist jetzt noch warm daher passt
sie perfekt und die soll auch nicht so
dünnflüssig sein
jetzt kommt es hier rein und dann können
wir gleich probieren
so bei diesem rezept habe ich mir jetzt
gedacht brauche ich drei verkaufter
kommt dass six anderes essen sonst nix
anderes essen was hast du hat gegriffen
mandarine gegessen bio hätte man der
rede gegessen bío bío
ich warte mal aber könnt ihr den
gefallen tun ja schon so machen kannst
du suchen
und so perfekt jetzt können die drei
affen des monkey brett verkauft für das
rezept monkey brat ok also stand ich
habe gegoogelt warum weil das sind so
kleine bällchen und die könnt ihr euch
jetzt durchs abzupfen praktisch
entnehmen
und dann dachte ich mich sowieso heißes
proto weil affen anscheinend auch hessen
abzupfen und das mit der hand essen ja
ich habe auch nie muss ehrlich sagen
gesichter gab es besser ja ich habe aber
auch noch in affen gesehen mit süßem
hefegebäck habe auch nicht gesehen
deswegen können wir einen gefallen tun
anderen einer stelle abreißen weil wir
müssen noch fotos machen
der größte aber vielleicht so jetzt geht
auch und die sind gefüllt mit nougat und
dann kannst du gern noch in die wertung
des salzburger gold er griff diesen
gefühlt minute war mal was ich denn nun
kann ich nur sagen mogelpackung
okay okay mehr war es okay okay alles
klar sieht es aus wenn alle mobils da
rein
wo war schon geschmeckt übrigen kader
einen pullover gefeiert den einen bunten
da dachte ich mir das konzert gefeiert
er ist mal ganz kurz und sagt mal ganz
kurz wie schmeckt was ihr wollt aber
fertig hast du jetzt ich sage dass drei
affen bist du noch klein war
kennt ihr das vielleicht noch weil bei
uns zu hause
so habe bei ihr daheim castella proben
zwar gab es ist gut wenn hier gab es
keine unterlage weil ja gab es nur trade
für arme kinder um mithilfe bei uns
völlig normal
du hast mutter genommen und auch die
butter hast du mont und genauso schmeckt
nur wahrheit sagen und ich habe in der
türkei prostata immer nutella mit rama
gegessen aber die rahmer oben drauf habt
ihr wirklich schon gemacht
ich muss noch leider und dann kann ich
es euch wieder geben und immer gemeinde
dann gebe ich es ein bisschen und
gemeinsame fotos auf jeden fall gemacht
dass umweg nach das ist so als kongenial
ich finde das geht echt super schnell
einfach im ofen das mit dem schälchen
hier perfekt und das ist die musik
remich mit gebackene also das schälchen
mit gebacken aber ihr seht ihr das geht
gut weg und dann habe ich die
vanillesoße auf dem herd gekocht also
dass noch immer überlegt wie man das mit
zupacken auch ich glaube das hat nicht
funktioniert weil die muss man hören
gerne und dann war da noch immer drin
das ist der perfekte wasserdampf effekt
und erweitert damit wenn du das team
fühlen würde ich mit das herz hat mit
kräuterbutter füllen und dann sollen den
sand und also worauf warten wir mal
cooles monkey brett und kohle machen
also wenn ihr das rezept nach machen
wollten sally sap oder auf meinem blog
abwehr innenblock der ebene ist die
fotos ist aber kalt oder ja was schmeckt
auch kalt er habe ich bei uns warum wir
bei einigen zu können
wir bereiten uns dann nochmal erwärmung
um spaß mit seiner figur machen der
arbeitet doch diesmal an
[Musik]